hello and welcome to this video play
practice w7 never played her all rights
a very fresh account so we get a cake
category and fell probably if he goes
for c4 c6 is the alternative but back
when I regularly played this kind of
openings I always played like that I'm
sticking with this pleased to have some
vague idea what to do our black wants to
provoke further exchanges to make it a
bit easier to play like this because
black has less space and likes to trade
a little bit this is why white tries to
avoid the trade um ok who do a play civ
5 here or not I don't have to maybe I
just play in this way
shooting for 925 okay i take c 4 he
wants to take with the pawn
hmm I wonder and it looks really a bit
weird never it has some points this move
I can go in for it it looks very
weakening but it seems that he had it on
the radar as a possible continuation
okay gasps still I don't want to take
but I need to move the Queen here to
connect rooks 27 would be great but I
absolutely don't want to take on c4 yeah
okay maybe I should go back
Champy 5 is probably not a great idea
yeah it just looks to weakening we looks
like to beginning a move
yeah this is also may be angling for
Queen g4m is smooth yeah I'm sure little
bit unsure how to set up him trying for
Queen not 28 Queen c8 9 p-6 I can know I
can do this but yes it's check it's got
the check hmm ok so i go Quincy 8 you
can still check me how I really play
badly today check yeah e 6 is not
exactly a dream move wow what am I plane
here ok King edge I guess this wasn't
enough for their for the exchange so
couldn't play that
you would just go back
yeah it's intending to just invade with
Luke jf seven it's very very annoying
IDM rookie seven doesn't help Andy five
there's you kept seven as well see no
good no freedom
this is for rookie seven in case of rook
f7
taking you for he might snap probably
not d 5 but I can take the five so the
temple maybe you just place like look at
four or something like that this one
some more ambitious move also the better
move I guess moon q7 looks very shaky
time warning
very shaky play
97 is not possible here
no idea just pretty bad no root gave 70
can play
yeah if one side is playing as badly as
I did and the other side is playing well
it looks like a complete thrashing and
this is what it is really got totally
killed him wow black there's a great
session today yeah he just killed me I
played a couple of questionable moves
but he really played it well maybe I
should just take this 7 I don't know I
take em sorry I take the seven takes
before I mean check okay I'm just worse
I'm just roseum aah what what was wrong
here let's see i mean this is this is
kind of normal everything and I've got
two pairs of minor pieces traded so I'm
definitely okay here but what did I do
wrong him I did it wrong maybe Knight b6
is already slightly inaccurate the
engine wants to play Queen to c7
probably also aiming 45
q yeah this is a bit of awkward it
really is I don't want to take on see
form and my idea of going 95 is
obviously not possible f5 was a bit for
activity may be here in the computer
wants to do this this and just play 27 I
didn't want to do that due to do the
porn but maybe this is really not that
relevant the engine line doesn't look
too too frightening something like this
here my position is already strategist
bad it's passive and I've got weaknesses
and no activity Jim there 97 fof got I
can do this actually and I'm fine okay
cool look f7 wasn't even that big a deal
cool and I take the screen Queen takes
rook takes Bishop takes and I'm okay
that's funny okay now I was just
thinking I'm losing and he I'm losing
huh yeah it wasn't good that wasn't good
what a session okay thanks for watching